[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the history of a
group of rather famous or inFAMOUS
depending on who you ask Hogwarts
schoolmates known as the Marauders for
anyone unfamiliar with the group The
Marauders were made up before
school-aged Wizards who attended
Hogwarts in the 1970s all four were
Gryffindor students who over the course
of their first year at school became the
closest of friends their names were
James fossa Sirius Black Remus Lupine
and Peter Pettigrew but before we get
too far into the formation of this
friend group not to mention any mischief
and Adventures they got up to while at
school let's take a look at the origin
story of each of these Marauders
individually now there's really no
question as to which more order we
should look at first and that is James
Potter James is of course Harry Potter's
father the man who died trying to
protect his family from mode Voldemort
and while James's self-sacrifice is
likely how the majority of you will know
him there are many noteworthy things
that this talented young wizard who died
All Too Soon accomplished before he
stood up against one of the darkest
wizards of all time James Potter was
born on the 27th of March in the year
1960 to Fremont and euphemia Potter who
were both rather elderly even for
Magical beings within the Wizarding
World coming from a long line of
successful and inventive Wizards Fremont
was also an accomplished entrepreneur
known mainly for his invention of sleek
Easy's hair potion which he created in
1926 being that James was Fremont and
euphemia's only son he was left with a
rather handsome inheritance upon his
parents natural deaths which occurred
before Harry was born and so as you can
imagine James Potter grew up quite
comfortably as the only child of his
successful inventor who himself had come
from dynasty of wealthy witches and
wizards in many ways James a wealthy
pure blood English wizard was rather
accustomed to getting his own way and
while some of that entitlement and
arrogance may have shown through during
his time as a pupil at Hogwarts just
asks ever a Snape James became so much
more than the wizard equivalent of a
spoiled muggled trust fund kid and while
it may be controversial to say a lot of
this might have had to do with the
company that James decided to keep once
he arrived at the Hogwarts the first
being serious black whom he encountered
on the train to school yet Sirius
Black's background is a bit
controversial in itself and not
necessarily one that you may think could
result in the loyal courageous and
dedicated young wizard that black turned
out to be born on the 3rd of November in
1959 Sirius was a third of his name and
heir to the house of black his parents
were Orion and woolberger black both
room with the sentence from English
pureblood Wizarding families
serious had one younger brother named
regulus and was cousin to Bellatrix and
Narcissa black who went on to become
Bellatrix Lestrange and narcissus or
Malfoy respectively names you likely
know due to their dedication to evil the
dark arts and Lord Voldemort serious
name however alongside the majority of
his family was considered a traditional
black family name as it followed the
convention of naming the black children
after Stars constellations and galaxies
the house of black was also a notable
entry in the sacred 28 a directory of
pure blood families and dynasties a fact
that most of the family was immensely
proud of as just about every member of
the family believed wholeheartedly in
blood Purity and Supremacy which
typically resulted in members of the
black family being sorted into Slytherin
upon attending school at Hogwarts this
belief in blood Supremacy also meant
that the vast majority of the House of
black refused to consort with Muggles
mugglebones scribs and Wizarding
families who associated with the likes
of those in fact they would go so far as
to forbid members of the family from
marrying outside the pure blood class
and discerned relatives who did so or
who turned out to be squibs like many
families who were this devout to the
ideology of blood Purity the house of
black was also a proud supporter of the
dark arts and later Lord Voldemort but
not Sirius Sirius openly rebuked his
family's beliefs and was hopeful that he
would not be placed in southern house as
so many of his family members had been
before him a wish that was granted upon
his arrival at Hogwarts similarly
wishing to start anew his first year at
Hogwarts was Remus Lupine born Remus
John Lupine on the 10th of March 1960 to
Lyle and hope Lupine Remus was a
Half-Blood wizard whose childhood became
marred but the actions of one very
vengeful werewolf known as fenrir
greyback after being put on trial by the
ministry of magic accused of murdering
two muggled children greyback was
released believed by the majority of the
questioning committee at the time to be
a non-magical who had nothing to
do with the dads of the children Lyle on
the other hand who was also in the
committee that day noticed telltale
signs that greybag was indeed a werewolf
when the other members of the committee
refused to acknowledge that Lyle could
be right in a moment of frustration and
anger Mr Lupine shouted in front of
greyback that all werewolves were
soulless evil deserving nothing more
than death
sadly this one aggravated insult is what
led to greybach tracking down the Lupine
family within a year of being released
from that trial it's almost certain that
greyback intended to exact his Revenge
by killing Lyle's only son Remus however
Lyle was able to get three Miss's
bedroom in time to drive the werewolf
out casting powerful magic to defend
Remus but not before greybach had mauled
the boy his bite marks turning his son
into a full-fledged werewolf for the
remainder of his life
from then on Remus lived an incredibly
lonely life as his parents worked
tirelessly to conceal his condition and
find a cure to which there was none they
constantly moved from town to town in an
effort to stay ahead of any rumors and
Remus was forbidden to play with
children his own age for fear that he
may accidentally reveal himself
sadly all this was done in an effort to
protect Remus as The Wizarding world's
overall view of werewolves as stated by
Lyle himself was rather Prejudiced and
unkind of course there were a few
exceptions to this generalization
including the perspective of Professor
Alba Dumbledore who personally saw to it
that Remus would be able to safely
attend Hogwarts as well as that of three
good friends he would meet once he got
to the school the final Marauder was
Peter Pettigrew little is actually known
about Peter's childhood including the
exact date of his birth although it's
believed that he was born sometime in
1960 due to his first year at Hogwarts
being in 1971 alongside James Sirius and
Remus and while we do know that Peter's
mother was a witch his father's blood
status is unknown in fact just about
everything about Peter and who he really
was is rather uncertain which is likely
how he was able to so thoroughly fool
his future as friends in fact Peter was
one of Hogwarts only true hat stalls in
history meaning that the Sorting Hat
took over five minutes to finally Place
him in Gryffindor House over its other
choice of Slytherin and had the Sorting
Hat chosen differently for little Peter
Pettigrew who knows what might have
happened from there events of the future
including that of Harry and his families
may have turned out rather differently
indeed but as it were these four young
Wizards were all sorted into the same
house of Gryffindor which turned out to
be the very Foundation of four
Incredibly Close friendships attending
her goats together as gryffindor's from
1971 to 1978 James Sirius Remus and
Peter became Inseparable during their
first year at school James and Sirius
first met on Hogwarts Express and almost
instantly became her best mates later
that first day not long after the
Sorting ceremony the two boys then met
and took a rather immediate liking to a
shy and clever first year they learned
was named Remus Lupine Remus on his part
had allowed a slow seeming Peter to
follow him along and as a result the
four boys became a group that would
eventually be known in the years to come
as the Marauders
the name of the Marauders which Loosely
means Raiders plunderers or Pirates came
to be only after James Sirius and Peter
discovered remus's lycanthropy or rather
that he was a werewolf of course with
friends as close as these it would have
been near impossible for rumors to hide
his condition from the other boys
especially considering his monthly
disappearances in which he would go to
the safety of the shrieking Shack in
hogsmeade Village to transform into his
werewolf self
fearful that after so many lonely years
as a child his friends would desert him
should they find out his secret Remus
desperately wished to keep them in the
dark but as I said this was near
impossible and so Remus entrusted his
three friends with his secret and was
completely unprepared for what would
result sharing the reaction of James
Sirius and Peter with Harry decades
later and they didn't deserve me at all
instead they did something for me that
would make my Transformations not only
bearable but the best times of my life
there became anime guy which of course
brings me to the bit about the three
other Marauders becoming anime guy
meaning that they were able to transform
at will into an animal counterpart James
Sirius and Peter not wanting their
friend Remus to suffer in his monthly
Transformations alone took it upon
themselves to learn this bit of advanced
magic in which James learned how to
become a powerful Stag and became known
by the other orders as prongs Siri is
learn how to become a Shaggy black dog
and was deemed by the other boys as
padfoot Peter learned how to become a
large gray garden rat and was therefore
called wormtail and Remus who had little
choice in the matter was referred to by
the other boys as Mooney in
acknowledgment of his werewolf condition
in their animal forms they were able to
roam the castle grounds freely without
fear of being caught by Hogwarts
caretaker Argus vilch or his cat
assistant Mrs Norris in doing so the
boys were able to map out the castle in
a way previously thought unimaginable by
students who had attended Hogwarts
before them which is likely how they
ended up with the name for their group
I'm quite certain that in their eyes
their wanderings around the castle were
much like the plundering Expeditions of
pirates and these Expeditions are what
inevitably led to the invention of their
map of Mischief otherwise known as the
Marauders map the Marauders map then
served the four boys as a way of
expanding upon their mischief and
troublemaking for it magically
identified every living and non-living
being on the map using the homunculus
charm what this meant was regardless of
any magical concealments enchantments or
spells that a witch or wizard may be
using the map was able to identify their
whereabouts and label them with their
true name it even worked on the spirits
of the castle including the ghosts and
peeves the Poltergeist instances of the
map at work were demonstrated many times
throughout Harry's tenure at school for
example the map was able to show Harry's
location even when he was wearing the
invisibility cloak it also showed Peter
Pettigrew upon the map when he was in
his rat form during Harry's third year
and then again during the events of the
Triwizard Tournament it showed Barty
Crouch Jr despite the fact that he had
taken polyju's potion to resemble the
likeness of Professor Alistair Mad Eye
Moody in addition to the cleverness of
the map and its abilities to reveal any
witch or wizard on the castle grounds it
also had the ability to prevent access
to it this was specifically designed by
the Marauders in order to keep their
classmates over a Snape from discovering
their Mischief adventures and most
importantly remuses like anthropy
secrets in fact the map would even go so
far as to personally insult Severus if
he ever held it in his possession
normally disguise is a blank piece of
parchment the map was enchanted to only
reveal itself to those who knew how to
operate it 4. upon opening the map one
simply needed to tap the parchment paper
with one's wand and say the following
magic words I solemnly swear that I am
up to no good and then the map would
appear alongside the following words
Mooney wormtel padfoot and prongs
purveyors of AIDS to magical Mischief
Makers are proud to present the
Marauders map the map also had the
ability to hide itself upon command
again with the touch of a wand and the
magic phrase Mischief Managed sadly for
the foursome sometime near the end of
their time at Hogwarts the Marauders map
was confiscated by philge the caretaker
as filch was never able to get the map
to appear although he knew very well
that it was more than just a piece of
parchment he never did much with the map
other than keep it locked up in his
office in a draw labeled classified and
highly dangerous this is where a curious
pair of mischievous twins threatened
George Weasley discovered the map and
stole it many years later after the
Marauders graduated from Hogwarts in
1978 all four wizards joined the first
order of the Phoenix founded and run by
Albus Dumbledore the first order same as
the second operated with the goal of
putting a stop to Voldemort's first rise
to power of course one of the four Peter
Pettigrew had also secretly joined the
ranks of the dark lord himself playing
the role of double agent as a loyal
Death Eater not long after graduating
James Potter married Lily Evans sometime
between the summer of 1978 and the
Autumn of 1979. they had their first and
only child Harry soon after on the 31st
of July in 1980 but only a year later on
Halloween night 1981 all of their lives
changed forever Voldemort after hearing
a prophecy suggesting that a child
matching Harry Potter's description
would be his downfall went after the
Potter family alerted the fact that
Voldemort was coming for Harry James and
Lily decided to put their location in
the trust of a Secret Keeper originally
selecting Sirius as their keeper but
Sirius argued that he would be too
obvious a choice and persuaded James and
Lily to choose another less obvious but
equally as trustworthy also he thought
Peter Peter went on to betray The
Potters freely giving up James Lilly and
Harry's secret location to the dark lord
from there Voldemort easily tracked them
down first killing James who attempted
to stand between his family and the dark
lord and then murdering Lily when she
refused to get out of his way of course
this turned out to be Voldemort's
undoing as Lily's sacrificial love
protected Harry in away previously
unimaginable to the dark lord as a
shadow version of himself he scrambled
away not to be heard from again for over
a decade at this time Sirius hearing of
James and Lily's murders Tracked Down
Peter and confronted him on his betrayal
and in a moment of sinister Clarity
Peter cast magic that led to the deaths
of multiple innocent muggle bystanders
and disappeared into his animagus form
as a rat but not before cutting off his
own thumb and leaving it as proof that
Sirius had murdered him presumably
having blasted his body into pieces with
James and Lily also dead and serious
incorrectly believed to be the couple's
Secret Keeper he was apprehended and
sentenced to life imprisonment in The
Wizarding jail of Azkaban without trial
for the next 12 years Sirius remained
prisoner in Azkaban only surviving and
escaping thanks to his unregistered and
omega's form as a dog Peter also
remained in his rat form for likely the
entire decade weaseling his way into the
Weasley family's home as their pet rat
for his part Remus laid rather low
presumably devastated by the tragic loss
and betrayal of his best friends and
from what we know he didn't get up to
too much until he was invited to fill in
as Hogwarts defense against the dark
arts professor in Harry's third year at
school and indeed that was the year that
all three remaining Marauders met again
for the first time since the death of
their former friend James having escaped
from Azkaban Sirius was hell-bent on
finding Peter and revealing the truth
about his betrayal he managed to track
him to Hogwarts and recognize that he'd
ensconced himself within the family of
one of Harry's best friends luckily this
was also the year that Fred and George
Weasley had decided to share the
Marauders map with Harry and Ron saying
that they had little need for it anymore
as they had it all memorized which is
how Remus happened to stumble upon it
and see Peter labeled plain as day on
the map
it all came to head in the shrieking
Shack of all places and while Peter
ended up escaping yet again and Sirius
was unable to live as a free man at
least Remus and Harry at last knew the
truth as to what had happened with The
Potter's Secret Keeper that fateful
night in the end each of the Marauders
met their death fighting to keep Harry
alive there was of course James Harry's
father but after James the next to die
was serious who met his end fighting
alongside Harry in the ministry of
Magic's Department of mysteries in 1996
hit by a curse Sirius was flung backward
falling through the mystical Veil a
one-way portal into the realm of death
the next death was Peters who died from
the Fatal grip of his own Bewitched
silver hand in 1998 which had been a
gift from the dark lord Peter's hand
turned on him due to his hesitation to
harm Harry and finally we saw the demise
of Remus as he bravely battled alongside
Harry during the Battle of Hogwart Remus
died fighting beside his wife nymphadora
Tonks whom he'd married a year earlier
in July of 1997. they left behind a son
Edward Remus Teddy Lupine to whom Harry
was Godfather
and with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think what
did I miss please share your thoughts in
the comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel also be
sure to check out the content on Spotify
as well as extra content on my second
Channel Harry Potter Theory extra until
next time remember mischief managed